الى تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث افاد موقع
ريادوفكا العسكري الروسيه ان قوات فاجنر
باتت في عمق مركزي مدينه باخموت وانها على
بعد مئات معدوده من الامتار عن المبنى
الاداري للمدينه الموقع الى ان قوه تخوض
معارك عنيفه جنوبه غرب مخموت وتخترق
دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه بشكل تدريجي
واوضح ان تقدم قوات في منطقه كراسنوي جنوب
غربي باخموت وانها بات تسيطر على طريق
المؤدي الى تلك المنطقه
وفي الشرق الاوكراني بثت قوته لروسيا صورا
قالت لها تعود لتدمير مواقع اوكرانيه في
المنطقه الصناعيه في مدينه افديافكا وتظهر
اللقطات المصوره لحظه رصد المواقع
الاوكرانيه واستهدافها بشكل مباشر باسلحه
موجهه وتدميرها على حد قوله قوات دونيت
كالمواليه لروسيا
ايضا اكلت السلطات البواليه لروسيا ان
مدنيا اصيب بجروح في القصف الاوكراني
بالمدينه واشارت السلطات الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت امس خمسه احياء سكنيه
بنحو 100 قذيفه ما الحق اضرارا ماديه باحد
المباني السكنيه
في اثناء ذلك بثت القوات الروسيه صورا
لطائرات مسيره تابعه لها وهي تلقي منشورات
في مقاطعه
تدعو فيها القوات الاوكرانيه للاستسلام
عبر تطبيق تيليجرام مقطع فيديو قالت انه
يوثق القاء الجيش الروسي منشورات في مواقع
تابعه للجيش الاوكراني في زبروجيا تدعو
القوات الاوكرانيه للاستسلام وانقاذ
ارواحهم وفقا للوكاله وتشهد مقاطعات
وموجات من القصف الروسي بصواريخ والخذائف
منذ ايام عده
في المقابل قال نائب قائد قوات الدفاع
الاقليميه للقوات الاوكرانيه
ان عدد قوات هذه الوحده ارتفع الى عشرات
الالاف بعد كل بعد ان كان سته الاف قبل
الحرب واضاف صدق وانا جميع وحدات قوات
الدفاع الاقليميه لديها خبره قتاليه
وشاركت في الهجوم المضاد في خاركاز
فاضاف ان جنود الوحده يقومون حاليا باداء
مهامهم في المناطق الاكثر سخونه في بخمه